[INSTRUMENTAL MUSIC]
ZISL SLEPOVITCH: Hello.
My name is Zisl Slepovitch,
and I'm a musician-in-residence
at Yale University's Fortunoff
Video Archive for Holocaust
Testimonies.
This video series is
designed as a companion
to our album, "Where
is our Homeland?"
which is the first volume in
the Archive's ongoing effort
to present songs
and poems performed
by survivors in testimonies
given to the Fortunoff Archive
over the last 40 years.
You can learn more
about the project
on the Archive's website,
songsfromtestimonies.org.
"Where is our Homeland?
Songs from
Testimonies, Volume 1"
was recorded in 2019 by the
Zisl Slepovitch Ensemble,
featuring renowned
singer Sasha Lurje,
Craig Judelman on the violin,
Joshua Camp on the accordion,
keyboards, and guitar,
Dimitry Ishenko on the bass,
and myself on woodwinds.
The songs in this
collection differ vastly
in terms of style, social
and historical background,
language, and many
other aspects.
But collectively, they create
a multidimensional picture
of Jewish life before
and during World War II.
Today we'll talk about the song
that was written in German,
although the name is in
Hebrew, "Kadima," "Forward,"
Vorwarts in German.
And it was sung by
Itzchak S. Itzchak
was born in 1915
in Berlin, Germany.
He actively participated in
Jewish Zionist youth groups
and, according to his testimony,
established one himself.
In the interview,
given in Hebrew,
Itzchak recalls the
song, allegedly composed
by Akiva Lewinsky, born
in 1918 and died in 2000,
a prominent Zionist leader.
Here's a short clip
from his testimony.
ITZCHAK S.: but we
also adopted an anthem,
and it was a song
that was written
by Akiva Levinsky, that lives
today in the Ma'ayan Zvi group.
He was one of the leaders of our
youth group in the good days,
he made Aliyah fairly
early, it is though
a song in the German language.
The song says forward,
we will march forward,
we don't have time
to waste, we know
that the future is with
us, the good future, that
is roughly the first
stanza, the last stanza is
that we are fighting
for the honor of Israel,
we want a new generation,
to create, that is the song,
and the tune is of
course unforgettable,
and what is interesting
is that Ivo, when she was
under arrest, in a
prison, told me afterwards
that she hummed the
words of this song,
and that it gave her strength.
(SINGING) Kadima--Forward, march,
We have no time to lose.
We know, we carry
the future with us,
So we know we must march on.
That is the first
stanza, and the last one
- We fight for freedom,
equality, and justice, We
fight for the honor of Israel.
We want a new, strong breed.
We demand Jewish honor.
ZISL SLEPOVITCH:
"Kadima," "Vorwarts"
"Forward" is written in
the genre of a solemn,
probably military march,
typical for the anthems
and other officially
sponsored songs in Europe
and the Soviet
Union in the '30s.
Very few of the
ideologically charged songs,
be that Zionist,
Bundist, or communist,
were musically
idiomatically Jewish.
The composers, most
of them unknown to us,
and the survivors
themselves were
part of the multi-ethnic,
multilingual, and ultimately
cosmopolitan milieu
in which they grew up.
[INSTRUMENTAL MUSIC]
Kadima--Forward Forward, march,
We have no time to lose.
We know, we carry
the future with us,
So we know we must march on.
We know, we carry
the future with us,
So we know we must march on.
[INSTRUMENTAL MUSIC]
We fight for freedom,
equality, and justice,
We fight for the honor of Israel.
We want a new, strong breed.
We demand Jewish honor.
[INSTRUMENTAL MUSIC]
DEREK PENSLAR: When Itzchak
refers to this song,
he describes it as a hymn,
or a hymnon in Hebrew,
that was sung by members of
his German Jewish youth group
when they were in
hiding, or when
they were living
as an underground
during the Second World War.
But he does acknowledge
that it was written earlier,
during the Weimar period.
So let's talk a little
bit about this song
and what it tells us about
German Zionism during the 1920s
and the early '30s.
Well, first of
all, who wrote it?
Itzchak, in his
testimony, attributes it
to Akiva Lewinsky, who
was an important figure
in the state of Israel during
its first four decades.
He was a functionary
in the Jewish Agency,
he was the director
of Bank Hapoalim
Then he did a lot of
other important things.
So was he the guy?
Well, we do know that,
according to his biography,
he joined a German Jewish youth
group when he was a child--
when he was 9, evidently--
and that it was called Kadima.
Well, "Kadima" is
the name of the song.
We also know that he wrote
music and poetry as a youth.
Evidently, he wrote poems
from early childhood.
He was also a great aficionado
of Hebrew from an early age,
and was committed to moving
to the Land of Israel.
But there we have a
little bit of a problem,
in that he moves to the
Land of Israel in 1934,
when he was 14 years old.
So if he wrote this song,
and he might very well have,
he did it when he was
10, 11, 12, 13 years old.
Now, it is a simple
song, so it is possible
that he wrote it then.
And in the testimony, Itzchak
sings it in both Hebrew
and in German,
and I wonder if it
was written in both languages.
So we can't be 100 percent
sure that Lewinsky wrote it,
but I think there's a
good chance that he did.
He was just a very gifted child.
Let me say a few
words about the song
itself, and its broader context.
It's a very German song--
in its cadence, in its
music, and in its language.
Some of it's a bit
disturbing, like the reference
to ein neues starkes
Geschlecht you know,
a new and strong
breed of humanity.
But to be fair, that
kind of language
was used not only in the
German world in the 1920s.
But what's interesting
also is the song
doesn't really say
anything specifically
about Jews, or about Judaism,
or about Aliyah, or about Eretz
Israel.
But there is something it refers
to twice-- it refers to honor,
or Ehre, Juedische Ehre
or the Ehre of Israel--
that is, the Jewish people.
And that's not a coincidence.
The Zionist movement,
from the very beginning,
was very concerned with honor.
And one doesn't
have to look only
at German Zionism for this.
Lev Pinsker, who
was from Odessa,
published a famous
pamphlet in 1882 called
"Self-Emancipation."
And it was very
much about honor--
about how the Jews need
to honor themselves
so they can be honored
by the rest of the world.
Honor and respect were central
in the Zionist writings
of Theodor Herzl.
So this is a theme that goes
back long before this song was
written.
And indeed, there were German
Zionist hymns of the 1910s,
the turn of the century,
and even earlier.
Theodor Herzl's favorite Zionist
hymn had been written in 1885,
but it was quite
popular in his own time.
And it has language
that in some ways
is quite different from
the song we're looking at,
but there's a
certain commonality.
I want to read just a
few lines from this poem.
It was called "There
Where the Cedar,"
and it begins like this.
There where the slender
cedar kisses the clouds,
and where the
Jordan's rapids flow,
there where my
father's ashes rest,
the Earth has drunk
the blood of Maccabees.
Now, the reference to
Maccabees is important here.
Akiva Lewinsky, we know that
he belonged to a youth group
called Kadima, which is
the name of this song.
Well, that youth group merged
with another group called
Tsofim or Scouts, and
it formed a new group
called Young Maccabees.
Comparing Jews to Maccabees,
to ancient warriors,
was found throughout
modern Jewish history,
but it's particularly
powerful in German Zionism.
And it goes back to 1914, when
the economist and sociologist
Franz Oppenheimer wrote an essay
called Alte und neue Makkabeer
"Old and New Maccabees."
Now, let me now
talk a little bit
about the background of
German Zionism of the 1920s.
On the first tape
of the testimony--
there's five different
tapes-- but on the first one,
Itzchak refers to
himself joining
Kadima when he was a child.
Now, this was an
organization that
grew out of a more famous
German Jewish youth group
called Blau-Weiss or Blue-White
that had been founded in 1912.
And it collapsed in 1926--
internal politics,
and youth groups
often sort of came and
went in Weimar Germany.
But what happened
over time, first
in Blau-Weiss, and then Kadima,
is that the movement's focus
changed.
Like the German youth
movement as a whole,
in the early 20th
century, the emphasis
was on individual cultivation--
personal experience
with nature, long
rambles through the forests,
music, and so forth.
In Germany and among
German Jewish youth
as well, as we get further into
the 1920s and the early '30s,
the youth movements
become more nationalistic.
And for the Jewish
youth movements,
a greater emphasis not just
on Zionism, but on Aliyah,
on immigration to Eretz Israel,
and Hakhshara preparation
for life in the Land of Israel
as a laborer, particularly
on a kibbutz.
Kadima was part of
a whole umbrella
group of German
Jewish youth groups
that had about 2,000
young people in all.
And I just want to
read you a sentence
from the founding statement
of this umbrella organization,
because it really gives you
a sense of what German youth
groups, German
Jewish youth groups,
were all about when you
get into the later '20s.
"We firmly believe
that in Palestine,
the cornerstone for a new
society is being laid.
We cannot do a thing here except
to prepare ourselves to become
worthy helpers of the
Palestinian workers,
and to teach the German Jewish
youth the ideal of a new
and dignified life
in Eretz Israel."
Note the emphasis not
only on labor, but also
on dignity, which
gets us back to honor
that I talked about earlier.
Now, how we judge the
seriousness of these
statements really
depends on perspective.
There were about
2,000 German Jewish
youth in these organizations.
Hundreds of them did wind
up moving to Eretz Israel
in the 1920s.
About 2,000 German Jews in
all moved to Eretz Israel.
That might not sound like many,
but there were 20,000 German
Jews in Zionistiche Vereinigung
für Deutschland the German
Zionist Organization.
And that's actually
quite a lot when
we think about the Jewish
population of Germany
being about half a million.
In the United States, which
had eight times as many Jews--
more than four million Jews--
there were about 60,000 Jews
total in the American Zionist
organizations, so three
times as many as in Germany,
but the community was
eight times larger.
And also, the American community
was about 13,000 members
of the American
Zionist Organization,
and the rest were in
Hadassah the women's Zionist
organization.
So it was split.
Immigration to the
land of Israel was low.
So actually, German Zionism
was much more committed
to Eretz Israel than
American Zionism.
And German Zionism was
more popular in Germany
than American Zionism
was in the United States.
And that might be
counter-intuitive.
But I think it's important
to keep that in mind.
The German Jewish world that
gave birth to this song,
then, was one where Zionism
was pretty prevalent--
not dominant, prevalent.
And within Zionism, there
was a serious commitment
to immigration, even if not all
the time realized in principle.
The fact that the
song itself doesn't
refer to the Land of Israel
is a bit of a red herring.
It may have been written by,
again, a very young man, still
a boy, whose own thinking was
in the process of formation.
Or perhaps, if it was
written by someone else,
it was written at a time
when the youth movement was
undergoing transformations
and debates
about how important the
Eretz Israel would be to it.
All this to say that we
can learn an awful lot
from a little song.
[INSTRUMENTAL MUSIC]